find your decisions I'm presh tall
Walker one chicken has the same weight
as one cat plus one owl two chickens
have the same weight as three Turtles
finally one owl and one turtle together
have the same weight as one cat the
question is how many owls will balance
exactly one cat this problem is adapted
from a tweet from man's head's maths
Department pause the video if you'd like
to give it a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
you could solve this problem using
algebra but I will present a visual
approach to this logic puzzle the weight
of one chicken is equal to that of one
cat plus one owl so two chickens will
have the weight of two cats and two owls
now we will add the weight of three owls
to both sides of the balance since we're
adding the same way to both sides it
doesn't affect the balance we also know
that one owl plus one turtle has the
same weight as one cat
we'll make this substitution on the
right hand side we can now remove equal
weight from both sides of the weighing
scale we'll remove the weight of two
cats we are left with one cat and five
vowels and this will be our answer it
takes exactly five vowels to balance one
cat and we've solved this puzzle using
just logic thanks for making mind your
decisions one of the best channels on
YouTube as always thanks for watching
and thanks for your support
[Music]